ich heiße eigentlich asbeck und war im
rahmen eines auslandseinsatzes in chart
als arzt tätig die erste woche im
einsatzgebiet im chart es war geprägt
von neuen erfahrungen vom klima für die
akklimatisierung phase sind der kompanie
wurde mir erleichtert durch meine
kollegen die gut zur hälfte ebenso aus
zivilen medizinern bestanden hat die mit
der ein oder anderen tipps gegeben haben
wie man sich das leben leichter
gestalten kann
in erinnerung geblieben ist mir ein
einsatz und zwar wurde uns mitgeteilt
dass bei den polnischen einheiten ein
unfall passiert ist wobei nur eine
person verletzt wurde
die wir dann nach einer stunde flug mit
dem hubschrauber dort ankamen fanden sie
mehrere verletzte vor
die momente von sechs verletzte das
erfordert natürlich ein gewisses maß und
improvisation und gemeinsam mit meinen
beiden sei es unter offizieren wie es
uns gelungen die sechs verletzten
soldaten gut versorgt nach hause zu
bringen
als wertvolle erfahrung was sich das
bewusstsein in schwierigen situationen
entscheidungen zu fällen die
durchzuziehen und das wiederum ist mir
glaube ich auch meiner späteren
berufslaufbahn zugute gekommen und ich
denke das war auch sehr wohl ein
argument dass meine bewerbung positiv
aufgenommen wurde